good morning it gets fried a quick
warning today's video is not suitable
for young children or anyone
so Hankey recently made a video in which
you briefly humped Google well a couple
days later nerdfighter extraordinaire
Maddy bouche posted you humping the
TARDIS on his tumblr and the humpy Hank
phenomenon was born the mix of my soup
that is whoo laughs after he's all right
Alan the pregnant heifer shot happy yeah
see a jewelry guy
I really hate you
yeah I'll be me
so half-assed that I can't stand up by
itself
thank you cannonball
through a Giga
and if you've been searching
if you grass your fancy garden see how a
deep end
move this so have happened
I forgot how to throw
came back to me like riding a bike
if you don't pay excesses milk
possess the pirate shot itself so we get
about deadness Kevin
see oh
every girl
I really
fools cuz this will happen
hanck at a historical moment like this I
am reminded of the great poet William
Butler Yeats who famously wrote and what
rough humpy Hank his hour come round at
last slouches toward YouTube to be born
nerdfighter karen kavett made that music
video she's awesome everyone should
subscribe to her Hank I have to go to
Amsterdam I'll see you on Monday